toujours sous très haute protection le
secrétaire général de l'onu poursuit son
déplacement en ukraine antonio gutiérrez
s'est d'abord rendu à borodianka villes
de la périphérie de kiev dévastée par
les bombardements aient lieu de
multiples exactions présumées d'alice
n'ont rien ne justifiera jamais cette
guerre
c'est inacceptable 28 j'imagine ma
famille dans une de ces maisons
complètement détruit
je vois mes petites-filles s'enfuir en
panique
abandonnant dahirel tous ces morts
antonio guterres s est aussi rendu à
butch à une autre banlieue de kiev une
ville devenue le symbole de la brutalité
et des violences russe les rapports se
multiplient sur les atrocités commission
les civils imputées aux forces russes
pendant l'occupation de la ville en mars
le procureur de la cour pénale
internationale a déjà ouvert une enquête
sur ces actes qui pourraient relever de
crimes de guerre
je suis satisfait que la cour pénale
internationale était saisi
je soutiens la cpi
et j'en appelle à la russie pour
qu'elles acceptent de coopérer avec elle
quand on parle de crimes de guerre il ne
faut pas oublier que le pire des crimes
c'est la guerre elle metz ils soient et
san antonio guterres s est aussi rendu
dans la ville d'hier pin où les combats
entre forces russes et ukrainiennes
furent particulièrement sanglant il ya
un mois le secrétaire général de l'onu
est arrivé mercredi soir en ukraine
après une étape mardi à moscou où il a
rencontré le président russe vladimir
poutine il a notamment réclamé à la
russie de collaborer avec l'onu pour
permettre l'évacuation des civils des
zones bombardées notamment dans l'est et
le sud de l'ukraine où les forces russes
concentrent leurs offensives